die kölner homöopathen doktor elvira
germes hat post bekommen so ganz edle
waffe im märz 2017 habe ich diese
urkunde bekommen also sehr werthaltig
gestaltet mit glitzernder schrift und
dem typischen focus siegel focus
empfehlung die empfohlenen ärzte in der
region
dr elvira germes radiologe ich hab
gedacht donnerwetter womit habe ich das
denn verdient einen sinn sehe ich
natürlich nicht darin weil ich seit 1998
nicht mehr als radiologin tätig bin also
ganz besonders bemerkenswert finde ich
dass ich wegen der praxisausstattung
hier belobigt werde meine praxis
ausstattung besteht aus einer couch
einem schreibtisch einem sessel einer
akupunktur liege und das war es auch
schon mit meiner praxis urkunde und
siegel beruhten auf objektiven kriterien
und würden vergeben von einem
qualifizierten team so hatte es der
focus geschrieben vielleicht alles nur
ein versehen dachte dr germes und griff
zum telefon
das erste mal wurde mir gesagt die sind
gerade nicht zu erreichen das zweite mal
wieder
und beim dritten mal sagte mir eine
genervte dame am telefon
also wenn die mich schon ausgesucht
haben dann werden sie auch ihre gründe
haben und ich sollte das jetzt mal
lassen
bitte anrufen habe ich dann auch getan
nachfragen beim focus die antwort frau
doktor med elvira germes führte den
facharzt für radiologie und wurde somit
auch unter dieser spezialisierung
gelistet nur dr germes praktiziert seit
mehr als 20 jahren nicht mehr in ihrem
alten fachgebiet und nur als geschenk
war die urkunde auch nicht gedacht als
ich sie bekam fand ich das erst mal
lustig bis skurril weil es ja hinten und
vorne nicht stimmt und spätestens auf
der zweiten seite als ich von der summe
das war mir klar dass das ein
unmoralischen und auch unethischen
hintergrund hat ja das ist nicht in
ordnung
1900 euro sollte die werbung mit der
focus okubo kosten gezahlt hat dr gerne
es nicht verantwortlich für das focus
siegel geschäft ist burkhard graßmann
geschäftsführer beim burda verlag 2017
sprache der medien fachblatt crest news
von einem zweistelligen millionenumsatz
mit wunderbaren renditen und kraß man
weiter wir bieten allen 280.000 ärzten
in deutschland die möglichkeit sich
darzustellen
eine einfache suche im netz zeigt mir
focus vergibt die siegel laut eigenen
angaben nach objektiver methodik und
einem punktesystem
besonders wichtig kollegen empfehlungen
facharzt und zusatzbezeichnungen
und die mitgliedschaft in
fachgesellschaften
der kinder- und jugendarzt dr stefan
nolte arbeitet seit 1992 in marburg 2017
bekam auch er einen dicken umschlag vom
burda verlag
ich habe mir dann aufgemacht und dann
herzlichen glückwunsch sie sind
ausgewählt worden für unsere focus liste
der ärzte und dann habe ich ja genau
drauf und dann dr stefan arnold
psychotherapeut marburg biedenkopf und
habe ich gedacht da ist ja komisch
eigentlich bin ich ja als kinder- und
jugendarzt niedergelassen 2018 lagen
weitere umschläge in der post diesmal
war er als hausarzt empfohlen worden
im nächsten jahr 119 kommt wieder so
einen umschlag versteht dann mit einmal
dr stefan heinrich nolte tropenmediziner
und noch eine urkunde
dr stefan raab heute palliativmediziner
und dann wiederum die urkunde kinder und
jugendarzt und wiederum die urkunde
hausarzt also das heißt jetzt habe ich
schon vier auszeichnungen spiel habe
viermal der im folder arzt in der region
focus teilt auf nachfrage mit dr nolte
sei auf grundlage offizieller
information und eigener angaben so
zugeordnet worden
es ist möglich dass die auf dieser
grundlage entstandene zuordnung der
spezialisierung nicht zu 100 prozent mit
der persönlichen auffassung der ärzte
hinsichtlich ihrer schwerpunktsetzungen
übereinstimmt doch de erneute ist sauer
weil es einfach schlichtweg nicht
richtig ist was darauf will ich könnte
einen tropenmediziner bin sicherlich
nicht der top palliativmediziner es gibt
ja kollegen zum beispiel die im hospiz
wohl um die uhr dienst machen die die
sterbenskranke menschen betreuen und
deswegen möchte ich damit auch nicht
werben und kann ich damit auch nicht
werden
mit dem fokus siegel werben kostet de
erneute sollte eine lizenzgebühr von
1900 euro zahlen pro urkunde
das wären für die vier siegel 7600 euro
auf dieses angebot hat auch dr nolte
verzichtet
bad homburg die zentrale zur bekämpfung
unlauteren wettbewerbs
christiane köber beobachtet das
ziegelgeschäft mit sorge
es darf nicht irreführend sein
irreführende werbung liegt dann vor wenn
ich als verbraucher etwas erwarte was
ich tatsächlich nicht bekomme das heißt
in den hier geschilderten fällen ist der
sachverhalt ja relativ einfach wenn ich
lese hier ist einer empfohlen als
tropenmediziner dann erwarte ich einen
tropenmediziner mit der entsprechenden
ausbildung hat es sie überrascht
die fälle die ich ihnen geschilderte
also in dieser intensität habe ich davon
noch nicht gehört also das sind ja
wirklich dass der gruppe irreführende
fälle schon kann man sagen das heißt die
ärzte die das jetzt so verwendet hätten
die werden ja wirklich in teufels küche
gekommen wenn die damit geworben hätten
fokus war es den vorwurf der irreführung
zurück zitat wir sind mit unseren auf
qualitätsdaten aus verlässlichen und
auch amtlichen quellen basierenden
erhebungen einzigartig in deutschland
weshalb man nicht von irreführung
sprechen kann
ich stelle fest immer mehr ärzte nutzen
die focus siegel
auch die universitätsklinik gießen
marburg sie wurde 2009 10 ausgezeichnet
als top regionales und top nationales
krankenhaus dazu als top alzheimer top
parkinson und top nationales krankenhaus
unfallchirurgie ich fahre hin
die geschäftsleitung ist nicht zu einem
gespräch bereit aber ich bin verabredet
mit dem betriebsrat der klinik
halo ist der betriebsrat ich habe das
hier gerade gesehen hier dieses top
betriebsrates basteln
das ist eine persiflage satire ganz klar
in anspielung auf die vielen siegel die
hier verteilt wurden und von daher haben
wir uns natürlich auch den spaß gemacht
von uns dann entsprechend auszuzeichnen
die betriebsräte empfinden die focus
auszeichnungen für das uniklinikum als
hohen aus sicht von wolfgang denker und
klaus gaber leidet die klinik unter
personalmangel
sie präsentieren beschwerden von
mitarbeitern die sich überlastet fühlen
es gibt dinge die nicht gemacht werden
können wie dark hat zeichen kontrolle
pupillen kontrolle kurven dokumentation
verzögerten medikamenteneinnahme für
patienten sind sehr viele dinge die da
gespielt hat werden die im argen liegen
die aber auch ganz klar dokumentieren
den personalmangel
immer wieder geht es um sogenannte
überlastungsanzeigen das sind auch
abteilungen wieder ein siegel bekommen
haben es gibt auch solche
überlastungsanzeigen von stationen
beispielsweise sagte orthopädie
unfallchirurgie haben sind ja auch
siegel zertifiziert aber auch da auf
diesen bereichen gibt es
überlastungsanzeigen ich bearbeite schon
diese überlastungsanzeigen seit jahren
das macht einen schon wütend wenn ich
merke dass ich seit jahren nichts ändert
die uniklinik gießen marburg habe ich
mehrfach um stellungnahme zu den
vorwürfen gebeten die antwort wir haben
uns entschieden an ihrer befragung nicht
teilzunehmen
berlin zu besuch in der klinik havel
höhe
auch andere deutsche verlage sind in der
siegel geschäft eingestiegen
chefarzt dr friedman chart bekam sogar
ein internationales angebot aus saudi
arabien sein haus könne zur besten
klinik der welt gewählt werden
wenn man dann das kleingedruckte liest
das ist eigentlich ganz interessant
stellt mann plötzlich fest naja man muss
eigentlich auch dafür bezahlen da werden
größenordnung 10.000 12.000 15.000 euro
wenn man dann von diesem siegel
plötzlich gebrauch machen möchte dass
das schönste angebot war unter den 100
weltbesten krankenhäusern zu sein
da fand man sich dann zwischen dubai und
mayo klinik wieder was man nicht ernst
nehmen kann
würden sie denn das geld zahlen bist du
nicht wir sind ja es gibt ja genügend
qualitätskriterien in der in der medizin
gibt transparenz daten an denen
beteiligen wir uns allgemein als
krankenhaus selbstverständlich aber
daran nicht wer einen arzt oder eine
klinik sucht kann mit hilfe der
sogenannten weissen liste fündig werden
kostenfreie rat empfohlen von
verbraucherzentralen zu finden im netz
unter der webseite gesund bund de
experten sind überzeugt der einen arzt
sucht braucht unabhängige empfehlungen
ja ganz offenbar dienen siegel so
tatsächlich bei vielen menschen als
kaufentscheidung und umso wichtiger ist
es eben gegen auswirkt so vorzugehen
gegen falsche siege gegen nicht richtig
zustande gekommene siegel und man kann
wirklich dem verbraucher immer nur sagen
nicht unbedingt von siegeln blenden
lassen sondern das wirklich auch
kritisch hinterfragen
[Musik]